trying to welcome in Germany
this visit is
your very first trip abroad
as the new king, honored majesty,
that is a great personal
gesture and
at the same time I think it is an important sign for the
German-British relations when
today exactly six years to the day after
Great Britain left  of the
European Union,
we are starting a new chapter
together as friends and partners,
we are now looking ahead
and that is why we are beginning this
state visit very consciously
with an issue that is crucial for
all of our future on this planet,
the human task of
sustainability,
energy transition and climate protection,
ladies  and gentlemen because so important
and so historically grown the German-
British relations are
only in this year our countries will be
literally connected with each other
2021 the construction work for an
underwater cable between the Isle of
Grain and Wilhelmshaven will begin
and in just a few years electricity will be available for the
first time between the United
Kingdom and Germany this
first
direct
electricity connection between our
two countries flows between two of the largest
energy markets in Europe
this is a key project we secure
the supply by
mutually balancing out fluctuations in demand and we
mainly feed in electricity from renewable
sources
even if the power cable is low
to the ground  Hidden by the North Sea even if
you won't see the power cable
this first direct transmission of electricity
clearly shows how closely Germany and
the UK are
working together to make our economies
climate neutral. For me
this is an encouraging example,
as is Your Majesty's visit to us all at
the German-British  Relationships are close to her heart
as well as her visit
is an encouragement
the support of a livable planet prompted
Her Majesty
to act very early on
because it is about nothing less than the
future of mankind about a
livable planet for us, for our
children and all future generations  As
we come together here today,
we are also sending a message to our
citizens, we see the
dramatic urgency in the fight against
climate change, and we are taking
on that task
many of the decisions needed
to reach the goals agreed in the Paris Climate Agreement
as early as this decade  reach for
Germany means that we have
seven intensive years ahead of us in which we will
reduce our emissions
modernize the economy and transport
have to make our houses and apartments more energy-efficient
these next few years will therefore require
an enormous effort we will
have to do significantly more than before
and we have to do it even faster
but the good news is
we have it in our own hands we
know and we have most of the
technologies we need on the way to
climate neutrality we can
now create the conditions for
tomorrow's prosperity
we magiscy ladies and gentleman a
break
charles to champion  health in nutrition
S in the Berlin energy transition Dialogue
have come to Palace
[music] [
music]
[applause]
[music]